depuis ce mercredi matin cette photo
signée de lafp diffusée en boucle sur
les chaînes françaises cet homme de 22
ans capuche sur la tête s'appelle
Alexandre dosi il vient de reconnaître
ce midi être l'auteur de l'agression
queur d'un militaire le 25 mai à la
défense mais l'enquête ne fait que
commencer est placer sous l'autorité du
parquet il faut respecter les phases de
cette enquête mais enfin nous avons
considéré le parquet et la police
judiciaire ont considéré que cet homme
était suffisamment dangereux à la fois
pour le placer sous le t pour placer
cette enquête sous l'autorité du parquet
antiterroriste et pour mener une action
qui a conduit à son arrestation à son
interpellation ce matin c'est grâce à
ces images provenant d'une caméra de
surveillance de la gare parisienne que
son arrestation par une brigade de la
police judiciaire de Paris et une
brigade criminelle a été rendu possible
à la verrière aux alentours de 6h du
matin le suspect originaire du PET en
Yveline avait quitté le domicile
familial depuis 8 mois pour celui d'un
ami situé donc ici dans le quartier du
Bois de l'étan même les gens du quartier
le il le trouvait un peu bizarre parce
qu'il était un peu des fois on le voyait
à la mosquée mais d'un autre côté il
était il buvait un peu d'alcool donc il
cherchait je pense que c'était c'est il
faut pas faire l'amalgame c'était pas un
un bon musulman c'était pas un vrai
musulman moi je connais un peu les
mosquées du coin il y a pas de personne
qui est en doctrine je pense que c'était
vraiment une personne isolée c'est un
fait isolé et cette personneelà se
cherchait et elle a fait ça peut-être
pour par rapport au au au fait de
Londres il voulait faire une concurrence
ù je n pas la moindre idée cherche
d'exlication mais seul lui pourra pourra
la donner quoi français converti un
islam radical depuis 4 ans Alexandre
dosi était connu des services de police
pour plusieurs vols le militaire blessé
au coup a lui retrouvé sa famille lundi
avec une incapacité totale de travail de
10 jours